[Música]
buenas tardes oigan déjenme decirles
algo tengo muchísimos nervios de estar
aquí es un honor estar ahorita con
ustedes yo podría iniciar diciéndoles mi
historia de vida lo que hago lo que
busco pero no va a ser así les voy a
decir que me encanta la locución de
radio me encanta la locución comercial y
es una de mis más grandes pasiones en la
vida estar atrás del micrófono y eso sí
soy repostero de mentiritas porque de
mentiritas bueno porque llamase
repostería y yo me como todo lo que
ellas por si no se nota no
en uno de esos días libres que en verdad
tengo recuerdo que me voy a la para la
computadora pongo una película y me
pongo a ver leer una película de héroes
la película está tan buena en lo que iba
avanzando me pongo a pensar todos verán
a los héroes y los villanos como yo los
veo o solo será cosa mía y es por eso si
me permiten quiero hacer una dinámica
con ustedes el día de hoy pero dar
ciertas características de héroes y
villanos y si están de acuerdo
quiero que levanten la mano si no están
de acuerdo la dejan abajo luego dará un
ejemplo mi camisa es blanca están de
acuerdo
si no estás de acuerdo dejar la mano
abajo te paras y te llamas al
oftalmólogo inmediatamente
vamos con las preguntas el héroe y el
villano tienen que tener un traje o
vestimenta que los distinga
aunque el villano es feo en el interior
y feo en el exterior
no levanten la mano el loro y el villano
tienen superpoderes
y por último tú eres está quiero que se
la contesten en su cabeza tú eres un
héroe o eres un villano en el momento en
el que te hice esta pregunta hiciste un
juicio propio donde todas las
características que tienes de héroe las
tiradas a la basura y llegaste una sola
conclusión pero es igual a bueno y
villano es igual a malo por lo que te
pusiste a reflexionar en todo lo que
habías hecho en tu vida así que si le
vueltas te un chanclas a tu hijo porque
te caía mal y te consideras un villano
eso contó y te empezó hasta juzgar pues
déjame decirte algo no importa lo que
hayas pensado o respondido estás mal
somos una combinación de ambas está en
nuestra naturaleza en un estudio
publicado en psychology today por el
doctor steve taylor quien es un
catedrático en la universidad de leeds
baked en londres nos habla sobre la
flexibilidad del bien y del mal en el
ser humano lo que este estudio nos dice
en pocas palabras es que para que el ser
humano haga algo bueno tiene que estar
una situación totalmente empática pero
para que el ser humano haga algo malo
tiene que estar una situación totalmente
egoísta la pregunta aquí es
acaso no somos empáticos y egoístas en
toda nuestra vida es decir somos
empáticos con nuestra familia con
nuestros amigos hasta con las personas
que no conocemos somos egoístas en
nuestro trabajo en nuestra escuela en
nuestras metas en nuestras convicciones
y siempre hagamos lo que hagamos va a
haber se va a ver una persona que nos
juzgue míralo sale a las 8 de la noche y
ni siquiera tiempo para la familia no
este chavo nada más está en yo yo yo yo
yo te vas al empático míralo en puro
voluntariado con los amigos y él cuando
la escuela cuando le suena y creemos que
hay personas que tienen este superpoder
de poder tener las cosas correctas en
equilibrio luego dar dos ejemplos
perfectos
steve jobs y la madre teresa de calcuta
personajes que sin duda alguna han
dejado una huella en el mundo todos
hemos escuchado visto o leído sobre
ellos y tienen el título de héroes
cierto steve jobs the man in the machine
un documental donde exponen como steve
jobs no
o sea su hija le daba una pensión de
cientos de dólares cuando él era un
multimillonario como su director de
ingenieros perdió a toda su familia
porque no lo dejaba de salir de la
oficina hasta que acabara el proyecto
sin contar los suicidios que hubieron
dentro de apple por el alta exigencia
laboral que había dentro de la empresa
eugenio un documental de la madre teresa
de calcuta en la cual expone cómo se
reutilizaban las jeringas en los
moribundos la falta de analgésicos el
lavado de dinero dentro de dicha
institución
y bueno y sin contar todas las
influencias políticas que tenía la madre
y por qué me estás diciendo esto güey
todos son malos entonces no apoyo no 150
millones de dólares a instituciones de
salud educación y trasplante de órganos
y yo me atrevería a decir que steve jobs
nos llevó una era en donde cambiamos
todo nos cambió la vida gracias a la
tecnología que trajo la madre teresa de
calcuta nos de enseñanzas de amor de de
cuidado al prójimo pero sobre todo nos
enseñó cómo la fe y la cercanía con el
ser humano puede hacer cosas
poderosísimas que quiero decir con esto
que somos un gris como seres humanos nos
cuesta mucho pero mucho trabajo entender
que somos un gris nada más somos una
combinación de ambas cosas nos vamos al
blanco o al negro al bueno y al malo y
esta combinación de cosas está en todo
en nuestra vida e incluso en las
decisiones que tomamos
la relación que yo tenía con mi padre en
una relación rara un día podemos estar
abrazados muertos de risa como con
padres de cantina y al otro agarrados
del chongo en más no poder no tienen una
idea y hace dos años y tres meses una
enfermedad se llevó a mi padre
una enfermedad muy rara llamada síndrome
de poemes esta enfermedad restringió su
movilidad acumula más líquidos a tal
grado que tenía la agua en sus pulmones
y tos
era muy difícil ver a mi padre así no
pero con todo y todo y no sabía reírse
de la vida reírse con la vida y ser
feliz y fue un padre ejemplar para mi
hermana para mi hermano y para mi hasta
el último día de su vida cuando llegué a
ver problemas haciendo una casa en una
familia pasan dos cosas o la familia se
une o se disuelve y la mía se desintegró
no tienen una idea dime el problema que
quisieras y lo tenía en bodega y si no
llega la próxima semana joven
yo recuerdo que la presión en la casa
era tanta que yo me iba en el camión de
las seis y media de la mañana y
regresaba en el camión de las siete y
media de la noche mientras menos tiempo
estuviera en la casa mejor llegué a tal
punto que dije no puedo más esto me está
afectando mentalmente socialmente y
académicamente y me fui a méxico una una
situación en la cual estaba bastante
bien porque pues bueno me llegaban los
fines de semana a cuernavaca llegaba el
viernes en la noche vi a mi mamá el
sábado vi a mi papá también el sábado
nos acabamos el domingo era como bueno
que te la pases bien hasta luego y era
genial
en este año conocí gente maravillosa
lugares increíbles probé suerte en la
radio y funcionó conocí la independencia
en todos sus sentidos no saben el logro
que fue poderme mover en metro y el
metrobús en la ciudad de mexico solo no
tienen una idea
pasa el año y mi padre empieza a
empeorar empezó a ir a urgencias dos
veces al mes fácil por lo cual tenía que
ir a cuernavaca una semana o el mes
completo y un día mi papá se pone mal
llega la ambulancia por él y todos
pensábamos que se iba a estabilizar e
íbamos a regresar a casa el domingo para
ver ese programa que tanto odia vamos
pero él tanto amaba tercer milenio con
jaime maussan que cosas
pero no fue así
entramos con mi viejito
y salimos sin ella
fue algo muy fuerte y ahí fue donde
comenzó a mi juicio porque dije tuvo un
año que tal vez será donde él más me
necesitaba pero me fui a méxico
y no solamente el mío de toda la gente
seguramente quería que se muriera no lo
quería
no le importaba y crearme que que hay en
un hoyo muy bajo muy bajo y al ir
saliendo yo me acuerdo mucho de una
frase que difundir odín dupeyrón en
todas sus charlas todo ser humano
necesita una despensa básica en su vida
y esta despensa básica consta de tres
cosas huevos leche y terapia y así fue
como fui saliendo de este problema y si
efectivamente lo que hice fue egoísta
pero era un chamaco que no podía ver
como el hombre al que yo aspiraba a ser
la vida se lo estaba llevando poco a
poco como ese manto que yo llamaba
familia los problemas lo estaban
haciendo trizas
no podía haber yo eso y mi decisión fue
irme a méxico no fue la más correcta tal
vez no pero como decía mi difunto padre
lo hubiera no existe esas decisiones que
tomamos nos marcan y dejan cicatrices y
hay veces que no queremos ni voltearla
saber obviamente hay decisiones que
tomamos que nos marcan de alegría y de
gozo pero las que no queremos ver son
las que formaron a la persona que eres
hoy y las que vienen van a formar a la
persona que vas a hacer mañana yo por
eso los invito a que dejemos de intentar
ser personajes se encuentran en los
cómics se encuentran en las películas y
trataremos de ser mejores seres humanos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]